Nearly 350 years after he saved Vienna
from the Turks in 1683,
John Sobieski, the Polish king and
Christian hero, still has no monuments
in the Austrian capital.
This is not because one doesn't exist. A
26-ft high statue commissioned for the
occasion has for years been sitting in
storage in Poland, but because Viennese
politicians fear that honoring a man who
prevented the Muslim conquest of their
city might come off as, wait for it,
Islamophobic. According to a recent
Austrian news report, quote, "For years,
a planned monument to Polish King Jan
Sobieski on the Kahlenberg has been a
source of political controversy. Now the
debate has flared up again, this time
coming directly from the diplomatic
sphere."
Initial plans for a statue were drawn up
as early as 2013. The project was
approved in 2018, but later halted. At
the end of 2024, just a few months
before the Vienna elections in April
2025, City Councillor for Cultural
Affairs Verena Kaup-Hasler
finally gave the monument a definitive
rejection, saying that Vienna would,
quote, "not erect a stage that could be
instrumentalized for xenophobic
incitement as well as Islamophobic or
anti-Turkish sentiments." Matters have
since escalated. The Polish Embassy in
Vienna has now entered the fray. In an
interview published on January 25th,
2026, the Polish ambassador criticized
the city of Vienna for reneging after it
had, quote, "promised us the monument."
He added, quote, "Sobieski deserves to
be commemorated in Vienna. Without
Sobieski, Vienna's history would have
been different. You can't simply erase
his influence. The city of Vienna owes
Sobieski something." Indeed, it does. In
fact, to appreciate the significance of
this ongoing controversy, here's a brief
summary of what John Sobieski did to
save Vienna. In the summer of 1683, some
200,000 Ottoman Muslims invaded Austria,
slaughtering over 30,000 Christian
captives in the process, and laid siege
to Vienna.
For over 2 months, the holed-up and
vastly outnumbered Viennese suffered
plague, dysentery, starvation, and
casualties, especially among women and
children. Then, on September 12th, when
the city had reached its final
extremity, and the Muslims were about to
burst through, an anonymous English
eyewitness wrote, "After a siege of 60
days, accompanied with a thousand
difficulties, sicknesses, want of
provisions, and great effusion of blood,
after a million of cannon and musket
shot, bombs, and all sorts of fireworks,
which have changed the face of the
fairest and most flourishing city in the
world, disfiguring and ruining it,
heaven favorably heard the prayers and
tears of a cast-down and mournful
people. You see, the formidable king of
Poland, John Sobieski, had arrived at
the head of 65,000 horsemen burning to
avenge and deliver beleaguered Vienna.
It is not a city alone that we have to
save, but the whole of Christianity, of
which the city of Vienna is the
bulwark." Sobieski had told his men from
atop the Kahlenberg hill overlooking the
city before leading a thunderous
downhill cavalry charge, history's
largest, against the Muslim invaders and
annihilating them. Hence why, for
decades, many Poles and Austrians,
including the Austrian People's Party,
have been eager to establish a monument
to honor Sobieski on the same hill where
his army gathered. As seen, although
Vienna had agreed, or in the words of
the Polish ambassador, promised, the
city has since refused. Why? Because,
and to reiterate, Vienna will not erect
a stage which can be abused for
fomenting Islamophobia and anti-Turkic
sentiment. To quote councilwoman
Veronica Kaup-Hasler, interestingly and
despite her name, this Veronica looks
much more Turkic than Austrian. This
would make sense because after the Poles
saved the Viennese from Islam in 1683,
Vienna went on to welcome Islam in the
name of tolerance, multiculturalism,
diversity, and all that.
As a result, Vienna is now a bastion of
Islam inside of Europe.
Yes, that's right. Although once a
Catholic city and seat of the Holy Roman
Empire, hence why the Ottomans had
targeted it in 1683, today there are
more Muslim than Catholic students in
Vienna.
Let that sink in for a while.
And the mosques they and their parents
attend tend towards radicalization,
according to multiple reports. When two
young Muslim boys were arrested before
launching a terror attack on their
school in 2023,
they confessed that, quote, "We wanted
to shoot all the Christians in the
class." Why? Because, quote, "Killing
Christians takes us to paradise." Crime,
as might be expected, is also rampant in
Vienna, thanks precisely to this influx
of Muslim migrants.
According to a report titled "Austrians
Living in Fear as Violent Migrant Gangs
Carry Out Daily Attacks in Vienna,"
quote, "Muggings and beatings are
becoming commonplace in the historic
capital city, with passersby being
attacked on almost a daily basis."
The Praterstern area, just outside
central Vienna, is now controlled by
North Africans and is considered the
worst area in the city for crime.
Despite police increasing their presence
in the area, it has become riddled with
crime. On the other side of the city,
the area surrounding the West Railway
Station has been taken over by Afghans
who have been making headlines for all
the wrong reasons. Crimes carried out by
migrants in Austria have risen rapidly
over the past year as more arrive in the
country. Sex attacks carried out by
asylum seekers has become a serious
problem in Austria with a 133%
increase in migrant sex attacks in just
the past year since the migrant crisis
erupted. Indeed, as in other European
nations, sex crimes have skyrocketed in
Austria. According to one report,
"Hardly a day goes by without reports of
sex attacks at the hands of migrants."
After Muslim migrants assaulted and
tried to rape a blonde woman, police
responded by advising her to dye her
hair black. By the way, all these
reports and figures are from an article
I wrote on Austria in 2017. Since then,
the Muslim population of the city has
continued to grow. Meanwhile, all that
the Austrian government has done in the
face of this demographic change and the
Muslim aggression is pretend that it's
not happening. School textbooks
whitewash Islamic history, including the
aforementioned Siege of Vienna in 1683,
while demonizing Austria's own
intolerant Christian heritage. Austrians
are expected to cancel themselves as a
way to appease Muslims. Christmas
festivities are curtailed in Vienna and
other Muslim-heavy regions, even as the
outnumbered Catholic children are forced
to learn and recite Islamic verses come
Ramadan. In one instance, after picking
up her young son from school, one
Catholic mother was shocked to hear him
loudly and repeatedly chanting, "Allah!
Allah!" until she learned that for 2
months the entire class had been
compelled, on pain of punishment, to
memorize and chant Islamic incantations.
"It felt like a slap in my face," said
the mother in an interview. A little
wonder that a monument to John Sobieski,
the arch-enemy of they who now dominate
Vienna, is not allowed in the Austrian
capital he so famously saved. On the one
hand, masochistic Viennese officials do
not want to offend the descendants of
those Turks and Muslims who once
terrorized, slaughtered, and enslaved
the the of Vienna, and who are
themselves currently terrorizing them.
Again, A on the other hand, they have no
problem spitting the eyes of the
descendants of those poles who gave
their lives to save Vienna from Islam. I
often talk about the ongoing and zealous
attempts to erase and cancel the true
history between Islam and the West
unless more people begin to connect the
dots. And this has been a perfect
example. Bring back
the fire.
Bring back
the fire
and the righteous name.